I was an engineer that did a lot of the  actual assembly of this aircraft as well  as some of the control surface  adjustments this aircraft went from  design to construction to test flight in  around two months  this aircraft is a nine foot wingspan  weighs 30 pounds as a jet engine and is  capable of speeds in excess of 150 miles  per hour it's 80 percent 3d printed by  weight this aircraft was designed to  showcase how quickly we could go from  the design phase to building and test  flight it won't be available for sale we  are able to help designers build  lightweight structures using  thermoplastics as well as enable design  freedoms that are not possible to other  manufacturing processes and we are  always trying to help the aerospace  industry further adopt added  manufacturing